1996's twister was one of the biggest
box office hits of Helen Hunt's career
after working on the original film in
front of the camera only hunt wanted to
expand her involvement in the sequel she
wrote a script for twister 2 alongside
her blind spotting collaborators David
Diggs and Raphael Cal hunt also planned
to direct the sequel herself but could
not find a studio willing to play ball
hunt and Diggs both pointed to the
script's emphasis on diversity as the
possible reason why it was a non-starter
for the studio
speaking to Insider hunt explained I
tried to get it made with David and
Raphael and me writing it and all black
and brown stormchasers and they wouldn't
do it later on in the interview Diggs
elaborated that a factor for why the
movie was never made was for a quote
shady reason that he found to be a
typical issue in the Contemporary film
industry